-President Trump
has been scrambling
for literally any kind
of positive achievement
as he nears the end
of his first 100 days in office.
Meanwhile, he and Congress are
facing down an imminent deadline
to avoid a government shutdown.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump is nearing
the 100 day milestone
with record low approval ratings
and a White House
in constant chaos,
which means today
was the perfect day
for a jovial, well-rested
former President Obama
to show up in Chicago
for his first public appearance
after leaving office
and say this.
-So, uh...
what -- what's been going on
while I've been gone?
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles sarcastically ]
Everything!
Everything has been going on.
Of course, after that comment,
Obama threw on some shades,
kite surfed
out of the auditorium
and yelled,
"Somebody get me a mai tai."
But Obama's first
post-election public appearance
was especially well-timed,
because Saturday will mark the
100th day of Trump's presidency.
Which is traditionally
when presidents get
their first big report card
on their performance so far.
And this will shock you.
Most people
think he's not doing great.
-We have our brand-new NBC News
Wall Street Journal poll
so tell us
just how Americans think
the president is doing
as we approach Day 100.
In short, not well.
-The worst approval ratings
around the 100 day mark
for any president
in modern times.
-He laid out a very detailed
100 day contract he called it --
Obamacare, tax reform,
border wall funding,
infrastructure spending,
new trade tariffs,
labeling China
a currency manipulator,
ending the common core
education standards.
100 days in or one week
from 100 days anyway,
incomplete at best.
None of this,
none of this has been done.
-None of this has been done.
If this were a movie,
it would be called
"100 Dayz and Confused."
Now, the polls did have one bit
of good news for Trump,
which if a new election
were held today,
Trump would win over Clinton
43% to 40%.
And of course,
Trump could not help but brag
about those numbers,
tweeting yesterday...
Still?
Does he think he won
the popular vote the first time?
Because I got news for you,
buddy.
You can't still do something
you've never done before.
It's like me saying
"It's been 100 days,
but Rihanna
would still go out with me.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Thank you for sticking with me.
Nonetheless, the 100 day
report card is on the way.
And like every terrible student,
Trump is trying to turn an "F"
into an "A,"
tweeting last week...
Yeah, the 100 day report card
is an arbitrary,
meaningless political milestone
that most people care about.
Most people, that is,
except Donald Trump.
-I propose the contract
with the American voter.
It's a set of promises for what
I'll do in my first 100 days.
What follows
is my 100 day action plan
to make America great again.
Just think about
what we can accomplish
in the first 100 days
of a Trump administration.
-And then after
you thought about it,
tell me what you came up with,
because I've got nothing.
[ Laughter,
cheers and applause ]
So as the 100 day milestone
nears,
Trump has failed to deliver
on almost everyone of
his major legislative promises.
Now, there are many reasons for
this including Trumps ignorance
about the basic political
realities of governing.
In fact Trump is so ignorant,
he's ignorant
of his own ignorance.
For example, he apparently
just learned
that there were
different factions
within the Republican Party
and talked about
as if it was a brilliant insight
telling the AP
in an interview...
Trump is like
an annoying 8-year-old kid
that just got home from school.
Did you know fish can breathe
underwater by using their gills?
Yeah, Timmy, I did know that.
Everybody knows that,
now go suck on your juice box.
In fact, Trump even seems
to have trouble remembering
the names
of Congressional leaders
as we discover last week
when he kept referring to
House Speaker Paul Ryan as Ron
before catching himself
and trying to save it.
-My thanks goes to Speaker Ryan
who's represented the city for
nearly two decades in Congress.
And you know where he is?
He's with NATO, and --
So he has a good excuse.
I said, "Ron,
make sure these countries
start paying their bills
a little bit more.
You know, they're way,
way behind, Ron.
I'm gonna talk to you
about that, Ron."
But, Paul,
you're over with NATO,
get them to pay their bills.
-I said Ron, "I mean,
I'm talking to you, Ron.
Your names not Ron?
I meant Don.
I was talking to myself.
Don, you've got to get them
to pay their bills.
Good idea, Don.
Thank you, Don."
[ Laughter ]
So, with less than a week
to the 100 day deadline,
the Trump himself champion,
the president
has failed to deliver
on nearly every one of
his major legislative promises.
How could things get any worse?
-Shutdown showdown.
-The White House is racing
to avoid marking the president's
first 100 days in office
with a government shutdown.
-If Congress doesn't send
President Trump
a the government funding
bill midnight on Friday,
the government
will run out of money
and a shutdown would begin.
-A sticking point
as you may know
is money for the wall
along our border with Mexico.
-He could be the first President
in history
to face a government shut down
in his first 100 days.
-Okay, but are we sure
the government
wasn't shutdown already?
Because it was reported recently
that...
Under Trump, our federal
government is staffed
as well as Duane Reade
on a Sunday morning.
Hello?
Hello, I need my heart pills.
Duane?
Reade?
So the White House is requesting
money for the border wall
and the bill
that funds the government.
But the crucial question is
will the president veto
any bill that does not include
money for the wall?
The government staying open
hangs on this question,
so when the AP asked Trump
that question point-blank,
this is what he said -- and this
is his full unedited answer.
As opposed to everything
up to that point,
which had been
super [bleep] telligible.
[ Laughter ]
So let's get back --
Let's get back
to his answer about the wall.
I'll tell you one thing,
that answer would have
definitely made
a much tougher chant
at Trump rallies.
Who's going to pay for the wall?
We don't know yet.
People want the border wall.
Your base definitely
wants to border wall.
You're base really wants it.
We've been to many rallies.
Unintelligible.
[ Applause ]
Now...
Trump's answer on the wall
might be confusing for you
for many reasons,
including the fact that,
as you may recall,
Trump promised repeatedly that
Mexico will pay for the wall.
And on Sunday he took to Twitter
to settle the discrepancy
with his signature bravado
declaring unequivocally
that
without any hesitation that...
Trump's tweets are starting to
sound like the fine print
on a contest to win
a free cruise.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Trump was also asked
how much the wall would cost?
And again
this is his real answer.
Man, even the biggest sucker
at the used car lot
knows to walk away when
the salesman says super-duper.
[ Laughter ]
And I'll tell you what,
I like you.
I'm gonna throw
the undercoating for free.
I just have to talk
to my manager, super-duper.
Now publicly, Republicans
and the Trump administration
have downplayed the risk
of a government shutdown
over border wall funding.
But privately,
they seem excited.
One unnamed top White House
official told the New Yorker...
We've all been saying "get outta
here, it's too ridiculous"
for two years,
yet here he is.
Get out of here!
So, Trump...
[ Cheers and applause ]
So, Trump obviously has very few
concrete achievements
to celebrate
his first 100 days.
Which of course left Trump brag
about the thing he loves to brag
about the most -- ratings.
In fact Trump is so enamored
by ratings,
he's even basing major personnel
decisions on them.
The Washington Post reported
yesterday
that when the prospect
of firing Sean Spicer came up
in a recent meeting,
Trump replied...
Yeah, everyone tunes in
to watch Sean Spicer
for the same reason this video
has 31 million views.
[ Grunting ]
[ Laughter ]
Incidentally Trump just made
that guy Secretary of Pools.
[ Laughter ]
So Trump is facing a 100 day
milestone
with virtually no successes
to brag about,
which may be why, when asked
by reporters last week
about
the sudden flurry of activity
and how his administration
was doing
as it neared
the 100 day deadline,
he resorted to the most
meaningless platitudes possible.
-It's going to be great.
It'll happen.
-You're gonna do healthcare
and tax reform?
-It'll happen.
We'll see what happens.
No particular rush,
but we'll see with happens.
But healthcare is coming along
well.
Government is coming along
really well.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the President
of the United States saying
government is coming along
really well.
It's like going home to your
wife and saying,
"Hello, wife, our marriage
is coming along really well."
This has been "A Closer Look."
[ Cheers and applause ]